now Paulie lost a bet you'll appreciate
this we're on Friday he's got to eat
just vegetables while the rest of us
eats meat oh my god that's death that
you're on death's doorstep when that
happens but you can't even have green
they can't even put parsley on your
plate well parsley is okay as long as it
can be removed somehow it got ingrained
in whatever else I had ordered no no and
you know it's funny it's not just green
it's it's mushrooms mushrooms cook
mushrooms or viwers onions
terrible I had a big old rib eye last
night with some mashed potatoes I mean
I'm in hog heaven
all right I don't know if you're in hog
heaven on Sunday night in Foxboro when
the fog started to roll in how do you
adjust as the play-by-play guy when that
happened well first of all I thought at
the beginning of the game it was just
all the fireworks they'd settle off and
there's always you know a haze in say
diem when they do that and then all of a
sudden it wasn't going away and when the
Paige food Patriots would score they
would shoot off the rifles north and
then it it's at a certain point I said
we'll wait a second this is more than
that Fred Goodell he said this is the
fog because of the plane to shoot the
aerials is grounded so this thing rolls
in and it's uh getting thicker and
thicker but you know Dan I have
experience with this in the 1981 Gator
Bowl in Jacksonville Florida between
North Carolina and Arkansas I'm doing
the game on ABC and my partner is Arab
Parseghian and the fog rolls in I think
in the second quarter and then in the
second half it is totally obscured in
those years of course I mean think where
we were technologically we had I don't
know maybe ten cameras of which perhaps
two were on the sidelines and you didn't
have you know the little cameras that
you have right now that you can place
anywhere and the hand hills and all of
the rest so we had to shoot that game
from two sidelines handheld cameras the
other night the great thing about this
was that you know Freddie and drew
Hezekiah for a great director they
adjust it and in in 1981 you didn't have
this
I can but I thought the other night when
you know we went down to that low Skycam
shot from behind the quarterback at
least you could sort of see what was
happening and certainly on running plays
it gave you a pretty good a pretty good
idea of what was taking place passing
plays were tough but as a play-by-play
announcer at a game like that damn what
I would do is I would look at the field
which was obscured just to see when the
team broke the huddle what the the basic
formation was do they line up tight they
have two backs they have three wide they
are four wide and then once I saw where
they were going with the formation then
I couldn't see anything else so I had to
go back to the monitor and call it off
off that camera so the running plays
were fairly easy if you know a 40-yard
pass downfield
you're just guessing but tougher for you
is play-by-play or Cris Collinsworth as
the analyst and replays I would say
maybe for him a little bit more because
he has you know access to different
views of each play I think some of them
were pretty good not as good as that you
know they obviously are when the when
the sky is clear but you know he was
able to you know he kind of worked
through it and it's like calling an
audible and you do the best you can you
know that the audience understands
what's going on and then drew punch up
that shot oh they had the handheld
camera behind us to see what we saw and
you know this was this was foggy bottom
comes through Foxborough but you've
called games in fog and rain and snow
you were there for the earthquake in
1989 I mean you've kind of seen all the
elements here haven't you
right and we call the game in Minnesota
when it was you know four below zero and
you know the game in which Blair Walsh
Manila Hannibal at the end and it was
four below and it only felt like you
know that was Ice Station zebra that's
night day that was a day game and in
Minneapolis so I've done games when it's
been a hundred and eight and I've done
games when it's been - for fog when
right you know if you're around long
enough then you'll wind up doing
everything you saw Michaels coming up
this Sunday night it'll be Detroit and
the Pittsburgh Steelers on football
night in America Sunday Night Football
we were talking about Rob Gronkowski is
he a Hall of Famer right now in your
opinion
he's on the he's on the verge I would
think it would be if he didn't do
anything else in his career I would say
the odds would be tilted to his not
getting in because I know the way the
voters look at things and they want you
know they want a lengthy career and all
of that he's been hurt a lot he's missed
a lot of games one he's played he's been
tremendous but I would say you know you
give another couple of years and if he's
typical Rob Gronkowski and he wins
another Super Bowl I guess he doesn't
even have to do that I mean he's already
he's had his share of success
yeah I mean he's on the edge and you
know you get that of that voting at the
end and I I don't know what what makes
the difference what I've heard through
the years is that you need you need a
sponsor
yeah booster a guy who goes in there and
convinces the electorate that you are
the guy if he finds the right guy he
probably gets it who does Carson Wen's
remind you hmm good question not sure at
this point but I do know he's fun to
watch you know got to see most of the
game the other night I just like his I
like what he I just like his confidence
and we you know we had him a couple of
times last year and I just liked the way
he walked in the room so I'm not sure
physically who he'd remind me of but
he's a guy who you know he came in the
room last year on the to get to times we
had him and and he he was solid in terms
of what he was talking about his
preparation you know all these guys
danced around and don't give you really
good information and and sometimes you
gonna begin to wonder if they know as
much as they should know but he did and
I think he's got a heck of a future but
when you go into these meetings explain
this if you sit down with Belichick or
Andy Reid or Mike Tomlin how how
forthcoming are they with information as
to what their game plan is for that
Sunday night well it's not so much you
know the game plan
look we've met with all of these guys
dozens of times
I mean I've I've been in meetings with
Bill Belichick since he was the
defensive coordinator of the Giants in
86 that's a long time and a lot of games
and you know as the head coach with
Cleveland
and obviously the last 17 years in New
England it's not you know you're really
not going in and saying what's your game
plan first of all Chris Collinsworth can
figure out what the game plan is before
the coach even begins to talk about that
and the coaches have a tremendous amount
of respect for Chris because he's
watched every you know imaginable piece
of film or tape or whatever understands
it better than anybody and he can talk
to the coaches on a level where they
know he knows exactly what's going on
who's playing well who's not playing
well so they know so there's a there's a
mutual respect there a lot of times what
we're doing in these meetings is trying
to get a little story that's a little
bit different personalize the guy you
know we're talking with Dan Quinn the
other day of the of the Falcons and
we're going through you know who's what
he thinks it was team at this particular
point you know how the games have have
stacked up for him what he hopes to have
accomplished in Foxborough on Sunday
night but I thought one of the more
interesting things was we said to him at
one point night you know you started
your coaching career at William and Mary
in 1994 and one of us said did you cross
over with Mike Conlon who was a wide
receiver he said yes he said I'm like
I'm a young assistant coach and I'm
hanging out with Colin who's a player
and so they go all the way back and then
he told us a story about earlier this
season
Pittsburgh played Atlanta in the
preseason game they're shaking hands
after the game and he says to Mike hey
let's meet in Minnesota in February on
Superbowl so it's that kind of lean
stuff like that and Erie's a lot of fun
with Belichick yeah you you learn
certain things would bill also he loves
to talk about the history of the game I
mean he's a true historian and it's so
funny I think I alluded to this on the
air the other night he's a guy who lives
in the here and now he doesn't want to
go back to last week but he will go back
to 1970 when he worked for Ted
marchibroda he made 25 bucks so the
meetings with these guys or you know
especially the guys who we've been with
for years
there there it's not as if they come you
know they say hey you know here's how
we're gonna open up the game with the
bomb or you know whatever we're gonna do
no huddle no it's not that so much is
this a real overview of the team and you
know just human interest of Justin
Timberlake's sat down with Mike Tirico
and before the interview ended had this
to say everybody shaking their booty our
goals that make our Michael's dance
Michaels if we can get you to shake your
booty at Super Bowl halftime show by the
way we can start that hashtag hashtag Al
Michaels that will be the icing on the
cake how do you have a official response
to Justin Timberlake well I sort of do
you know I you really don't like the
trend on Twitter if you don't have to so
I'm not on Twitter but I hear that you
know it got a lot of hits or or whatever
you call them yeah belch echoes in what
snap face or whatever it is so I guess
I'm all over the truck but here's the
thing with this and I really appreciate
Justin coming out and staying this and
he's a great guy and a fantastic
fantastic performer but there are a
couple of things in motion here number
one I'm trying to get through spinal
stenosis
so before I'm able to do any of this
stuff do I get a couple of epidurals
secondly I mean I never was a very good
dancer I know the Box step and when I
was in high school and sure Chubby
Checker was doing the twist I could sort
of do that and then I mean to me you
know I thought maybe Lawrence walk would
be the halftime performant so you know
Dancing with the Stars not only with her
I'd be thrown out on the first show I'd
be thrown out you know before we even
got to rehearsal now that's not oh no
that's not an official no it sounds like
it's not an official though I'd like to
be able to step up and and do this but
but I don't know what I'm supposed to do
at this point then what do I do now you
tell me I think at that time I don't
overthink it just you know comes
halftime you go down let the music take
over let it sort of just flow like a
wave on the ocean over you and then
you dance with Justin Timberlake for one
song half a song maybe just a course and
that's it then you walk on and then I
could rip rip open my shirt no no
there's no wardrobe malfunctions this
time around but I mean but I would have
a tight shirt you know so we stretching
the chest no of course something the
buttons which would about of course they
want oh my god this would be you talking
about a ratings disaster that would Oh
Dan I don't know what to do at this
particular point you know what I'd like
to do it my ear old granddaughter wants
to give me lessons I mean this is this
is what I'm reduced to with this new
component through epidurals and an
eight-year-old giving me dance lessons
we'll talk to you on Sunday night you
bet Thank You bun that's Al Michaels for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on Direct TV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]